in the half hour
um so let's start with a simple example
of search right so we've got an array of
integers
and we've got a query we need to find it
in the array
so we can just do binary search start in
the middle and and there we go and we
find
the element okay um
an alternative if we have a prediction
is start with the predicted place
and then use sort of a a doubling binary
search look one to the left then two to
the left and four to the left
until we find an interval where it
appears and then we can use
sort of a binary search once we find the
actual interval
that the element appears in but the idea
is to use a prediction to help start us
on our search all right so binary search
is order login
and what you can see or it's a pretty
simple analysis this prediction based
search
is order log of whatever your prediction
error is
right and here i'm not counting whatever
time there was to do the prediction i'm
just talking about the search
the searches order log prediction error
steps
um we'll use the term robust generally
speaking to say that it still behaves
nicely in the worst case right so even
in the worst case
this search is also order log n you're
only going to lose
maybe a a constant factor a factor
generally of two
and this other property that we might
call consistent in the best case
the prediction based search is as good
as it can be it's constant time
all right so this is just a very simple
example to show
that you know if we have good machine
learning this can improve traditional
algorithms and again this is this is not
surprising
you can think of this even perhaps as a
variation on an
on the long known interpolation search
but here we sort of put a machine
learning type framework on it
and it's meant to be an example to show
where how machine learning could
possibly
improve traditional algorithms
all right so now let me look at uh
another example scheduling
so suppose we have two types of jobs
short jobs and long jobs
natural goal is to minimize the total
waiting time or the expected waiting
time per person
so if you didn't know anything about the
jobs rate the natural thing you would do
depending on
what your notion of fairness might be
might be first come first serve
right i'll handle people in the or jobs
in the order in which they come in
or you might say if you you had all the
jobs you know
waiting you might say well i'll
randomize the job order but of course if
you know the job sizes
the sort of uh you know algorithms
first year algorithms class exercise is
to prove that the best thing to do is to
just put the short jobs first and this
minimizes the total waiting time
because you get the short jobs out of
the way
all right so now suppose we had a
machine learning algorithm that would
simply predict for us whether jobs were
short or long
then we would actually say well i don't
know if things are short or long but i
might as well use this predictor
right and so then you can ask questions
like well if there's classification
error
and you know for me um working in
probability as i do i like simple models
where
short jobs are misclassified with some
probability and long jobs are
misclassified with sub probability you
know what can you gain from using the
learning algorithm
over you know just doing nothing
assuming things come in
either a random order or or a worst case
order
um because the
computer science community loves price
of type statements i i've referred to
this as a price of misprediction
so you know think of it as a as a yet
another variation on the competitive
ratio
so what is the worst case ratio of the
expected total waiting time
using this machine learning algorithm
compared to having the actual
perfect information so the idea is we
have some algorithm
right i'm not necessarily even saying
it's an optimal algorithm
but even just for any algorithm you can
say well what's the cost
compared to having this imperfect
information compared
to what we would have for perfect
information
and here you know you can get a result
that says that this depends
very nicely in sort of a linear fashion
on
the total error p plus q
all right so takeaways
as we go forward this was a pretty
simple or simplistic model
but to me it highlights that you know
bad predictions can can actually be
you know pretty helpful um right so if
we just considered
like a random order for instance the
sort of do nothing
that would be p and q are both a half
right and if you do instead like
well maybe i have a bad predictor it's
only right
you know 40 it's only right 60 percent
of the time and it's wrong 40
of the time well that's still good it
still gives you an advantage it's still
doing something for you in a non-trivial
amount
right so um you know even bad
predictions can can potentially be
helpful
um and in particular that we can really
treat these problems mathematically
all right so now um of course just
scheduling
you know short or long jobs isn't
necessarily
interesting uh long ago in what seems
like previous lifetimes i used to study
like queues with cueing theory models
and this seemed like a good place to
come back to
when considering machine learning so
this is something i've looked at
um you know so to start just a reminder
of standard queuing
models you usually assume the arrival
process is poisson arrivals which just
means
exponentially distributed service times
which just means that
the arrival process is memoryless
there's a way to think about it for
service times if you're
trying to write down equations it's
often nice to imagine exponential
service times
um but in practice you usually see more
of a heavy tail distribution
and of course what we were saying before
is in in simple models you don't
actually know the service times which
would explain why you
would use a service discipline like
first come first serve
but of course if you knew the service
times you you do something different or
better
um and in some systems you might have
preemption in some systems you you might
not have preemption
right so the main sort of result is that
from original cueing theory
for standard queues mm-1 queues that's
poisson arrivals exponential
exponentially distributed service times
the m stand for memory lists if you do a
first in first
out your arrivals are should be you know
your arrival rate should be less than
the the time per service um we can scale
the service times to have mean one
then the sort of basic fundamental
results of queuing theory is the
expected time in the system
it grows like one over one minus lambda
so as lambda gets close to one
this asymptote asymptote of the one
minus lambda
really starts to hit you hard
if you know the service times of course
you can do better right so
there are variations there's their
shortest job first which is
you know not preemptive it's just
whenever you're going to take a job you
take the shortest job
you have in the system shortest
remaining processing time
is a preemptive so you win it
if a new job comes in it may preempt
based on
the remaining processing time left um
preemptive shortest job first the
shortest job first
but with preemption so you're always
basing it on the actual time
not the remaining processing time but
you can still have preemption for this
and all of these are known
to have formula you know the queuing
theorists have figured out these models
in the the case where there's poisson
arrivals and for general service time
distributions
um so now you can go back and say well
what if we had something that didn't
give us the actual service times but
just predictions
so we have corresponding policies of
predicted job first predicted remaining
service time
or pre preemptive shortest predicted job
first
um i looked at a pretty straight
forward model or simple model where we
think of having a
the service distribution is given by a
two-dimensional density function
so that gives you both the true service
time and the predicted service time
so you can think of instead of just
thinking of the service times as being
governed by a distribution
both the the service and predicted
service times are given by by a joint
distribution
um so it turns out that you know
you can go back in through the system
and i'm not going to
go through the math here define all the
terms but that's in
sort of the paper i i have on this you
can get a pretty simple formula for the
price of misprediction for the shortest
predicted job first
where you know some of these quantities
the primed versions or the y
versions or for the predicted times and
the x
or the the unprimed versions or for the
regular service times
and it turns out you can perfor perform
these same sort of derivations for
for these other sorts of systems as well
um and then you know you can look at
some examples so
a very simple example let's say the
service times
are taken to be exponentially
distributed with mean one
and then the predicted service time is
itself an exponential
random variable but its mean is the true
mean
of whatever whatever the job is um it's
just a toy example but it's a toy
example that turns out to be sort of
mathematically nice to look at um
because of all those exponentials
and you know you can derive the
equations that say how it should behave
the equations and simulations
nicely match and and the key takeaways
are you get
you know big improvements over not using
any information particularly when you're
doing high loads
right so uh you know you can
again the the left the srpt is to the
shortest remaining processing time
that's prpt is with the predictions
using predictions instead
and it's like sure you pay a price for
using predictions but you do a lot
better
than than doing nothing at all um and
this is
a natural sort of thing that we see
across situations
um some of the high level messages from
this work preemption is good but the
people know that
uh even weak predictions do well
and the idea of why do we predictions do
well is because
really you know we don't actually care
in this thing about the predictions
themselves being right
we just want the ordering of the jobs to
be right so
you don't even particularly need great
predictions
you need you know consistent predictions
or consistent with the
the actual ordering um and these systems
can be analyzed
um i've done some some further work
since then
i i on this sort of model i have looked
at what i call weak predictions
like what if you really only get a
single bit hint
um you know so essentially you just get
a hint as this job short or long
for some threshold you can set if you
like for your learning algorithm
if it's below the threshold you'd like
it to say it's short if it's above you'd
like it to say it's long
for a cue you can think of this as
answering the question okay a new job
has come in
i can either put it in the front or in
the back you know what should i do
should i put it in the front or in the
back i think this is actually a pretty
natural model for queuing type
scheduling um it may be an easier
prediction problem
just putting things in the front or the
back and then forgetting about the
predictions entirely
um seems like it'd be easier to
implement may be useful in situations
where you have limited communication
and again you can see sort of like
results where
where you have uh you know preemptive
versions where you preempt the job up
front or or don't
preamp the job up front um again the
high level takeaways are again under
under high loads um you get significant
gains even with
very little information from your
prediction
the gains i think are are worthwhile and
significant and are you know
generally closer to the optimal you know
or
you know or the optimal shortest
remaining processing time
or here with predictions shorts
predicted remaining processing time
than you might expect and i have some
other
you know results uh both analysis
and and uh simulations for
more heavy tail distributions and it you
actually see like for heavy tail
distributions
heavy tail distributions tend to do
really bad in first in first
out because a long job blocks the system
more frequently
and so for these sorts of things you get
even better
all right uh and apologize for speeding
through but let me
talk about some other things um some of
the original work in this area came in
from caching right you look at the
standard online
version of caching you have a cache of
size k elements arrive
if you you pay if when an element arrive
it's not in your cache and if it's
element isn't in the cache
you know you can put it in the cache if
you if you want to
right so melodies rule gives you the op
line optimal
so if you knew the future you could do
you know great things of course we don't
know the future but maybe we can come up
with some
prediction of the future all right so
this was
work by the chorus and vasilvitsky from
a couple years ago now so for every
arrival they try and predict the next
time it will
appear so this seems like a pretty
natural model you're just doing one
prediction each time so
they consider the absolute error and
again their goals here are these terms
we've used before of consistency and
robustness
so consistent is like when the error is
zero or
or close to zero the competitive ratio
should be very small
and yet at the same time it should be
robust right so it's both a nice
function of the air and if the error is
bad
it it eventually behaves like you know
not too much worse than
than just a regular online algorithm
that doesn't use the predictions
so the first thing you might guess to do
is just follow the predictions
evict the element that appears farthest
in the future
it turns out this does very badly is
this can be seen if you look at sort of
a repeating sequence
um where if you have like a single
misprediction for a
that causes you to keep it in the cache
and then you revolve around two items b
and c
you'll just keep kicking b and c out
after each other
right if you know you somehow thought a
is still coming
you need to sort of update your belief
somehow at some point
and kick a out to get a good competitive
ratio
all right so what they did is they
looked at a a version of the marker
algorithm
that used uh predictions and i won't get
into the details of that algorithm
but they had a number of results about
this predictive
marker algorithm and in particular
you know they had the sort of hybrid
algorithm said look if the algorithm
you know looks like it's behaving badly
at some point we can just switch back to
the marker algorithm
and do that in a way that that maintains
roughly
the competitive ratio of the marker
algorithm
but will do better if the predictions
are better
um and since then there there's been
continued work on the caching problem um
with
improved competitive ratios and some
simpler algorithms
by by uh rocky and wei um
and in this setting of online algorithms
we're seeing more and more
papers um covering this type of
prediction model so i've seen recently
papers on secretary problems
online matching page migration i think
more on the way
if you look at aaai iclr neurips
um you'll you'll be seeing more and more
of these
papers i think
so again online algorithms are a pretty
natural place to use these sort of
learning augmented algorithms these
algorithms with predictions
there are some formal notions of
consistency and robustness that help us
frame what our goals are or what we're
looking for
other online problems have been sort of
been studying in this framework but
there's still certainly plenty more to
do
all right my next quick topic
is has to do with streaming algorithms
so things like
frequency estimation which is a standard
sort of
put on your switch or network device
uh tool that you would want to have is
to get frequency estimations of things
going by
um the well-known sketches for this are
are count min
and the count sketch you know they they
approximate the counts for items
you know for instance the countmen
sketch you know we'll hash an item
um there are multiple rows it gets sort
of one location in each row
ups the count in that cell um and then
the minimum count associated with an
item
is is its approximate count and
you know i i should really like you know
let the builder come in and talk about
this but
um you know the problem with these sorts
of sketches are that you get collisions
right so
if you are an unfortunate low count item
um that happens to collide with high
count items and all of these cells
you're going to be
off in your prediction right and to a
lesser degree even if a bunch of low
count things all all hash together that
they may be
you know problems in the prediction
so what they notice it says look if we
could just remove the high count items
from the beginning we'd clearly get a
lot better results all around like if we
actually knew
what the high count items were well we
could just pull them out
assign them their own counter that way
they'd be very accurate
and you know they'd stop messing up all
the other items that have lower counts
and we get much better uh approximations
for
frequency estimation and so you know
this is what they looked at they said
well if we have a predictor for height
count items
can we use it to decide what to remove
and and explicitly count
right so you know essentially the
picture on the left is what what this
looks like an element comes in
and if you think it's going to be a
heavy item you give it its own
unique counter and say great i'll count
this separately i think it's heavy
and if it's not heavy we'll throw it
over to the countman sketch algorithm
and then they drive a whole bunch of
cool results on the right that i i don't
have time to get into
um but are in their paper and further
they show like
that this really really works in in
practice
um you know they're their versions
are the in the red the ideal versions
from the green
but in particular you can see that you
get uh roughly from these charts you get
big gains in accuracy from from using
these sort of learned models
all right so the last thing i'll quickly
talk about
as i rush through is about um learn
bloom filters so this is the way i came
into this
um uh you know someone suggested that i
should look at this paper by tim kraska
and others um tim prasca's at mit
about doing better than standard bloom
filters by using learning
um so i came into really skeptical and
and
you know sort of came out a believer you
know can we
do something about learning a set and
designing better bloom filters
right so the idea is that you use
machine learning to develop a predictor
is this an element in your set or not
and you use that to
enhance your bloom filter right so if
you can get a good enough
predictor you'll do well right so the
setup
is you just think of boom filters as a
binary classification problem
is this an element in this set is this
not an element in the set
the elements in the set themselves of
course can be your training
set for elements in the set you come up
with a bunch of negative examples
either from chosen elements or random
non-elements
you throw your favorite learning model
at it and the idea is that
the hope is you know you design a
a learning method that will give you a
number which
you should think of or intuitively
corresponds to
like a probability estimate is this in
the set or not
and then you can threshold that and say
well things that are above the threshold
are in the set
things that are below aren't now the
problem is that if you just do this sort
of prediction and threshold type scheme
you may get false negatives right there
may be some things that are in the set
that are predicted wrong
and so you know you need to do do
something about that because bloom
filters typically
are not supposed to have false negatives
so
you know anything that's actually a
negative you you
run through a backup filter right you
you sort of use the learned oracle
the learn filter as something to enhance
your
your backup bloom filter so you know
your learned oracle may cause false
positives but hopefully not too many
um you catch the the false negatives
with the backup filter
and the point is is that the backup
filter can be much smaller
potentially much much smaller than your
original bloom filter because it's not
including
every item in the site it's only
including the items in the set
that somehow were not correctly
identified by the learned oracle
right so the backup bloom filter would
be much smaller than an original bloom
filter
if your learned oracle is small then
again
you can get much less size um
and get similar or say or reduce false
positive rates
um so recently i i and one of my
students
eric nor teamed up with tim and one of
his students and tried to
you know come up with better versions of
this that are called the
partition learn bloom filter the idea
here is that as the score goes up
it should be a higher probability of the
query being a set element
so you should need fewer bits to you
know
to for a bloom filter for higher scores
so instead of having a single threshold
you'll have multiple thresholds
each with their own loom filter and you
can tune the learn bloom filter
accordingly right so the the picture
here
looks like you know sort of this on the
left you have your input
you get a score depending on the score
it then goes to
a specific backup bloom filter for you
know false negatives in that score range
and the picture on the right sort of
gives the intuition
that you know if f is the things that
are in the set g
is the things that aren't in the set
right you can afford to use
fewer bits for for things the ranges on
the right
than then on the left
all right so i will rush through this
quickly but just sort of say we were
able to cache this as an
optimization problem you know
you can think of it as a sequence of
steps you know
uh if you're given the partition
boundaries how do you optimize the bits
um it turned out that some really you
know once you do this optimization
problem things like
kl divergence and things magically show
up in the results which is kind of nice
and
and told us we were i think on the right
track
then we could figure out the issue of
given the number of partitions where do
you actually find the best
partition boundaries based on the
solution in step one
we could find you know how to optimize
the partition boundaries
using a dynamic programming formulation
right um again just just showing some
figures
um you know the the left data set here
is
a synthetic data set where we made up
the scores
and in particular we made up the scores
you can see sort of on the bottom
the way we we sort of wanted the scores
to be so
you know for keys the keys are
centered around or the bulk of them have
high scores many fewer of them have low
scores
whereas non-keys are the opposite
they're bulked up on the the low score
end
very few of them have high scores and
you know
in the chart we have the standard bloom
filter some various improvements
to the learn bloom filter and you know
we're able to do
you know better than all of them because
we're actually now solving the right
optimization problem
and when we have key and non-key
distributions this is for a url-based
data set
you know that that have similar sort of
key non-key
distributions as what we would hope or
expect we get very similar results
in settings where you know the key and
non-key distributions are not so great
you know again we still beat the the
prior results but naturally
by not as much there's sort of not as
much to gain um
when our classification is less good
all right so here the summary is
predictors can also be used to enhance
these types of data structures as well
you know the the kraska group has been
working on
various lines of uh indexed data
structures
i expect to see you know uh when i talk
about algorithms with predictions i
i don't mean to slight the data
structures that they should be in there
too
um just a quick i still have a minute so
i'll probably take two pyotr
um you know again this work doesn't
really come out of you know nowhere
there's
long been work on optimal algorithms
with advice
but they have been really more focused
on the idea of what is the complexity of
the optimal device
right so here the flavor is different
we're sort of focused on the issues of
you know what happens if we get
practical but noisy
advice that we have to feed to our
algorithms
of course like i said this fits in by in
the the whole general framework of
beyond worst case analysis
there is a book coming out shortly on
beyond worst case analysis
um that tim has been like the editor for
chapters by everyone
uh sergey vasivitsky and i worked
together too
you know we had been both working on
sort of uh survey talks and things and
put together sort of a survey article on
on this theme that will be in the book
um
so you know those if you wanted to look
for
for more information on this general
area um
here are a couple of of links you know
sergey's
survey um peter's course at mit
there was a summer workshop um on this
theme
again like i said we have a survey
article um it's up on the archive but
will also appear
as a book chapter um so you know
i think this is going to be a a growing
area it seems to be
you know although it's nascent it seems
to be
you know bursting out with lots of work
and what papers there's
tons of questions you know besides just
what problems are amenable to advice you
know
what things should be predicted can we
give feedback to the ml community like
we'd like your predictions to be
optimizing for this or to look like this
because that will help out our algorithm
the best and and can you all do that
um so i think lots lots of good
questions
uh to consider um and that's it
all right thanks michael uh you are
definitely an expert in compression
i didn't i didn't think it's possible to
compress all this material in half an
hour but you you did it
uh so we are just slightly over time
so if there is a a quick question uh go
ahead
uh otherwise we can just switch back to
gather town
and uh you can ask uh i don't know
michael do you plan to attend gather
town i i'll go in for
after this for a little bit all right
yeah so so if somebody has questions
uh you can ask michael gathertown and uh
jesse
posted the gather town link on the chat
so
like we all know where it is
all right so i don't see i don't see any
immediate questions so
uh we have a break and uh
see you guys in uh gather town